hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch this
Game of Thrones the loot train attack
video from HBO I don't know how old this
video is must be pretty old I think this
is a making-of thingy
so whatever tuck more tears on patreon
but everybody you request some Stefon
doing but about YouTube's today comes
from Canadian firefighter Lance door
let's check to his house away oh we
should broaden Jamie horses
[Music]
Oh battle death
[Music]
it was on the other side to hold
together in the period as the most
complex set of emotions about this
battle of anyone because he's got the
one he serves at one end and he's got
his brother who loves
that is a real shuttle for every piece
of his being is wishing interesting but
it can't and seeing firsthand my family
lose she's the aggressor and Jamie Braun
through therapy you see the pretty
conquering something like the loot tram
involves a lot of different departments
all working at sort of the very extremes
of their abilities I think this was a
difficult challenge because there are so
many different looks and phases of the
battle that come into play there's a lot
of continuity to make sure that we're in
the right space in the right part of the
process reflecting the right amount of
and then my feelings
[Music]
we'll call it a shadow tracker and we've
got a jib arm on that finally we've got
basically a souped up dune buggy with a
stabilized head on it that takes all the
bounce out just a nice steady smooth
shot to use over that one it is what's
called spider cam this is basically a
camera rig to a cable run between two
construction cranes and the camera very
quickly from one end to the other
[Music]
so just kind of worried distracted
but you are controlling it when there's
so much going on you just got upon us
every single bit of imagination you have
and just
that's amazing all the effect has to
mimic as though the flame is coming to
the sky so we'll always size up the
flame later and post will shoot elements
of flame against black but Sam here has
to make it feel that the impact of the
flame
is pushing along always quite a process
in the end with the fuel mix yeah but
they could literally write circles
around their enemies I think there was a
line in the outline that said it now
it's down to commitments do their tricks
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
a horse standing on a horse casually
stand up a fire
there was no challenge the difficulty
with 20 people is just that you wrap up
the safety aspect because there's more
people in harm's way we use this
basically like a cage thing going on and
saying breath is very poor
for ourselves as we go over this is just
a fear factor of course that we see fire
nevermind 2020 guys in one go it's it's
pretty
yeah Johnson it was very much an
all-hands-on-deck sequence as much as
we've ever had Oh buddy did an excellent
job hitting all the puzzle pieces
together this is big cinema but you get
to work in all those genres all rolled
into one fantastic world that's the part
I like you never know what they're gonna
do without the NSD even actually gets
bigger this shudders you just thought
this no it's no big challenge
I think you'll like the break just just
bask in the magic of cinema houses movie
magic does is one fool one battle yeah
didn't even cover the whole battle no
just like very specific just the Dragon
sequences at the battle they all
encompass a few minutes
that was intense man this is I like I
love watching stuff like this cuz this
is the kind of stuff that really makes
me appreciate the undertaking obviously
cuz they're they really broke down every
component it seemed like of that battle
you know from the ground up from
dressing it and making the environment
to all the different effect and it was
funny because like it's certain times
they would bring something I don't
really like oh yeah that would be its
whole own operation and it just reminds
you that it is like a big Rube Goldberg
machine we're like a bunch of things
have to be all coordinated and working
together at the same time to make this
happen yeah you know just criticize the
show yeah you know cuz we know who's
ever yeah who can spot each other in the
comments been people risk their lives
and stuff and a lot of professional
experts got together to make this happen
but you know like I was entertained for
45 minutes there's just a bunch of
fights no story
yeah one part of me has this slight
cynic of I kind of wish I don't watch
these because it could take away the
magic of some of the show but then at
the same time whenever I watch these I
do realize that I'm also in that seat of
I do take for granted just how much I
mean yeah they were covering a battle
moment not even the whole battle but the
amount of work these filmmakers and
everyone on set puts the put in for a
show at the end of the day is just a
television show and even though the show
means a lot to so many people we can
never take for granted just how much
work hundreds and hundreds and
[Music]
I've got HBO now and at 15 bucks a month
for all the television and then just to
get a little snippet of this for like
just for our own entertainment it's best
to just you know end olds in the
positive fandom side of all these things
I've seen what these guys are working so
hard to put together for us I'm just
very grateful because they're things
I'll just take for granted you know it's
easier to criticize when effects look
silly but how often do we I feel like
nowadays especially on the Internet
whenever I point out like man these
effects look great
there's always some comment is why I've
chosen us read comments lately one of
the main reasons of just like it's so
easy to just say the effects look good
such a cliche thing to say like well you
know it hours and hours and hours oh I'm
gonna give credit where credit's due the
effects look when they were showing like
the pre effects of the dragon and how
like all those early stages don't look
very good at when they show the actual
show footage like looks like a real
dragon yes like blowing all these people
up or something I I never even thought
of I just take it for granted all those
stuntmen that I have to rig something
for them to ride the horses that are a
key characters and be standing on the
horses while riding that's something I
just never never crossed my mind when I
watched that battle like oh wow how'd
they do that you know yeah I feel so
natural thing is that's the weird part
about so much in a movie or a TV show or
anything is that so many people I think
that's part of the conundrum that leads
to that kind of armchair critic
mentality or you know the way we don't
necessarily appreciate what goes into
these things is because they're supposed
to be invisible by the time it gets to
you because we always judge the final
product but we never really factor in
and we're welcome you and I are guilty
of this too world war forget to factor
in that well there are people who work
like many many many months on who spend
we spent like good portions of their
lives probably working on this show well
yeah I moved out Iceland or wherever
they shoot and you know yeah I'm
dedicated yeah we'll just well judge the
final product Oh boom
completely forget to give credit
or acknowledgement or gratitude to the
fact that people did labor upon this
thing for so many Albert's this how many
weeks and months you know well that's
the larger point is like that's why I
never take unless a movie or a show
actively upsets me in some kind of core
way where I just feel like ah whatever
kind of led to this project is rotten
like unless that I do not really take
much delight in laying into anything or
casting anything off frivolously just
because of the respect for the amount of
nobody wants to make something bad which
is kind of a cliched thing to say now
but you know for so many of the things
we see everybody wants it to turn out
good everybody's bringing their a a game
and their expertise and every production
is so many departments working over so
much time in so many different
coordinated lock steps that yeah like
it's really impressive when good stuff
comes together you know well yeah I mean
you can just see from this behind the
scenes in it of itself hell for this one
sequence on set there's hundreds of
people working together and then in post
there's tens of people working together
notes you know there's a lot if there's
so many different a variety of opinions
that the fact that they've managed to
come this far with the show and it's a
TV show you know something like this for
a movie will be very impressive too but
I think especially for a television
series the amount of wanting to up their
game up the ante and really just try to
make it look of that much bigger and
better every season bloat that blows my
mind how much labor they put into
because at the end of the day when
you're doing all these technicalities
for cool battle sequences they all have
to come back to the story you know yeah
how's the emotion here how's the
storyline because when I think of that
battle I I always think of the last
moment when Jamie is writing towards
Daenerys he's gonna kill her and then
broad tackles here and the dragon fires
yeah yeah that that's where I think it
was something I'm thinking the emotional
context of that scene was I didn't even
touch on here yeah that's what that's
where my mind goes to but I wouldn't
have felt any of that
that that weight of that moment of
course it allowed all the investment of
the characters over the years yadda
yadda yadda everybody but because of the
whole battle leading up to that moment
to you know yeah so you got to think
about not just does this look cool
that's the coordination of having to
really hammer in both and also the
amount of relying you have to do on your
team right because everybody's got to be
serving the greatest good of the show
and if that happens you know then hell
yeah and if departments falter yeah you
know so as much as I don't like dealing
with comments on when we cover Game of
Thrones yeah I just want to go back to
just enjoying the show I just want to go
back to just kick him back as if there
isn't a camera pointed at because this
will record the reactions this is an
event for you guys for us forever we all
want to be involved in it so yeah for
anyone who watches this show yeah hi so
I just wanna kick back with the show
just enjoy I want everyone just love
this slap especially this last season
gonna this is from Season seven but you
know this last season especially they've
come this far anyway
Lance door thank you so much for
requesting this dude this was an awesome
video got a lot more from it than I
expected to so it's a great
recommendation buddy then dude I
appreciate you hitting me up in my
patreon inbox as well saying you know
make sure to avoid Instagram and all
that because they're a major spoilers
for end game going around you know how
to keep a lookout dude
and fireman's instinct right they're
always looking out for people putting
out the fires online as well as in the
people world and he also I was saying
that he really hopes to start with
something Iron Throne
that'd be cool it's like going to be a
stark it's gonna be a land stir it's
gonna be great joy it's gonna be a great
you're just gonna see that come yeah
basketball yeah look at my [ __ ]
throne sitting suck it suck what fair
Lance show should move die so I start
putting out like stuntman and sister man
sister always pays is
it's - our patreon page all right guys
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and Game of
Thrones watch along with us on our
patreon page